everything that you're embodying as a
person is the example that you're
teaching your kids how to be so if life
is full of joy and happiness and like
going after life like that's what
they're gonna do if that's what your
life is all about that's gonna be them
they're gonna they're just gonna embody
that too this is a child who um is just
needs me and try is trying to figure out
the world and trying to understand the
littlest things what's so freeing what
some of the best advice you gave me when
I was like called you every other day
like okay now he's crying I don't know
why you know your advice was roll with
the punches and I that phrase really
stuck with me because rolling with the
punches just means being okay with chaos
maybe chaos is just crying when you
don't expect them to cry or waking up
earlier from their nap than you want
them to and it's more chaotic when you
have a child to take care of going from
not having a kid that is something that
I think can cause a lot of unnecessary
stress yes in the first time parenting
mode because every time they're crying
or every time something isn't going
exactly how you thought it would it
could be so easy to just like need the
answers but then I learned the more kids
I had that like you don't really need
the answers all the time all you need is
your love for them and doing your best
to figure out what they need in that
moment because they're doing the best to
communicate with you for New parents
just like letting that go and just
taking that stress off your shoulders
just be there for them baby's gonna
respond better to that yeah
that was my sister Hannah McNeely if you
don't know we're 14 months apart and
she's my very best friend this is my
second time having her on the podcast
and I'll likely be having her on every
time she visits Us in Hawaii these
conversations are a peek into how we
navigate different topics together and
she inspires me in so many ways as a
human mother and friend I love this
conversation as we get into an
unfiltered motherhood talk parenting and
sleep habits for children and babies
homeschooling money our relationship
together and with our partners and more
I hope you enjoy it too and feel
encouraged like you are part of the
conversation with us let's get into it
alright Hannah thanks so much for being
here are we recording now we're going
I know I'm such a perfectionist
yay over here how long have we been
taking time to set up if only people
know I know I know it's just it's just
ridiculous well thank you for having me
on your podcast it's good to be here and
I always like I was gonna visit and
you're like we should do another episode
and I forgot yeah and it should I should
do it I know so I didn't even think of
that and I was like okay I gotta get
some more podcast episodes because this
is my first episode after Dianne's been
born yeah that we're back in recording
and it feels really freaking good yeah
I'm so excited to get back into it and
you have like a I have a lot of ideas
for guests that I'd love to get on it
just takes a lot of work to like get
people here you know the coordinating
and the yeah just getting people on a
plane it's actually harder than it looks
yeah and you were coming to come visit
and meet Dagny and bring Cosmo and we've
had such a good time dagne's such an
angel she's so sweet she's got the
roundest head ever she does she's like
this perfect round head maybe you should
talk about your birth a little bit you
haven't really talked about on your
podcast like that's true I know there's
like overlap with your other other yeah
platforms but still like Ellen got her
Dream birth oh it was amazing I mean all
your birds were powering and beautiful
but yes you know but this birth was just
exceptional and so beautiful and just
lovely and you know what someone asked
me what it was like for us to build our
birth course together yeah like what was
it like working together sisters maybe
you can tell me what you think well it's
like working with me Hannah well Ellen
is
type A
yeah perfectionist and
obsessed with making things just like
perfect and look perfect and I'm we have
different skills we have different
strengths and which is one of the
reasons why like we worked so well
together the hard part is like hard
working remote it's like I was in Idaho
you're in Hawaii and it's just harder I
don't know yeah sending files and then
the four hour time difference and yeah
but
I don't know you you worked me hard
Ellen yes it was yeah it was interesting
for us to work together for the first
time because even though we have similar
type jobs we never like together created
something yeah and so that was when we
do
um ask each other for we we constantly
are texting each other for I don't know
title ideas how do you like this
thumbnail advice I need a video idea
like things like that like advice on
like how to handle whatever
um because we do the same gig
um but collaborating actually creating a
product together was was really
interesting yeah I don't think I could
work with anyone else yeah it's hard to
work with someone you know this is hard
in general when you're like creating a
product together but I think we work
really well together and understand each
other and have different strengths I
definitely there were definitely moments
where I'm like wait this is not no we
have to do it this way and you're like
really does it really happen and then in
the end it is better so I I understand
it I'm just
lazy like I'm I'm not a lazy person but
there are certain things that I just
don't want to spend the time on and I'm
like this will be so much better we have
to do it this way you're like are you
sure I'm like yes a thousand percent and
then we did it it's like oh yeah okay
that is yeah you're a hustler yeah but
so are you in different ways like you
are like a writer and I'm like wait a
second I'm so slow at writing because
when we're writing out like what we're
gonna put into this course like which
took a really long time a very long time
yeah and a lot of people might not know
like why we did the course together oh
yeah because I actually had well for
anyone who doesn't even know what the
heck are we talking about oh yeah what's
the course the empowered pregnancy and
birth course it's obviously this is more
of Ellen's brainchild I've had one baby
she's had five and we're both very
passionate about birth and you know
helping women
have really awesome experiences and
birth doesn't have to be it doesn't have
to be a really scary thing I know
sometimes it can be but yes and I've
been wanting to create like an
empowering pregnancy and birth course
for years but just never found the right
time for it but everything happens in
its time it all happens the way it's
supposed to and the way it unfolds is
always like later you look back and
you're like ah yes that's why I couldn't
do it earlier it makes sense like it
just all everything made sense in the
end but I really wanted to create this
birth course and launch it with like my
last birth like with this fifth baby I
was like that would be amazing to like
have the birth and then be like and if
you'd like to like learn all my tips on
what has helped me to have just tips
it's like I know deep dive it's like
yeah like if you haven't if you haven't
had a birth that is empowering and you
felt disempowered like you felt like
this isn't what I want to happen yeah
there is another way oh absolutely and
even if and if this is your first
pregnancy first birth and you're just so
lost there's so much information out
there this is everything you need to
know yeah everything that I wish I knew
and it's not it's not the stuff you
don't need to know like you don't yes
you don't need all the suckers yeah
there's something that's like it's too
much and I'm like I don't you don't need
that time for that you're pregnant you
don't have time for that yeah you gotta
just give me the information I need to
have my you know most empowering
beautiful pleasurable experience how do
I have an easier labor a shorter labor
you know all that stuff that I wish I
knew so long story short I came to a
place like halfway through my pregnancy
where I was like I'm not I don't have
time I can't I can't do it like I was
like about to get started on it I'm like
I just I don't think I have the time to
be able to create this course so I gave
up I essentially gave up and I was like
I'm just not gonna do it and I'm so
bummed Ellen is excited it's very thin
if you guys don't know like I know it
she makes it look really effortless but
she has a lot on her plate and it's yeah
you need the membership you do your your
main Channel Vlog you have the podcast
which is like so time consuming and and
then all of the children and making sure
oh yeah oh yeah the five children and
the children like making sure I'm
getting quality time with them like
that's my number one biggest priority
yeah you know and then I have all these
other things that I love but it's like I
wish if I could have any superpower it
would be to pause time like hands down
whenever when anyone asks like what
would be your number one superpower
desire would be that I could pause time
get everything I need to get done and
then just click play again yeah you know
what I'm saying like so I can just like
be like not lose time but that's just
not I mean we'll unpack that a little
bit because we don't have that
superpower and so the alternative is
either feeling really stressed all the
time and feeling like and like you know
there's the mom guilt we're especially
working mom guilt where you're like I
feel guilty when I'm not working I feel
like I'm guilty one and then there's not
working mom guilt too for like people
are like do I need to be working like am
I yes like they're saying I know some
moms who feel that as well but wait I
want to go back to yeah what I was gonna
say is that I essentially gave up I
called Hannah Hannah knew how much I
wanted to create this course and how
many like ideas I had for this course
and I was like I don't have time I'm so
bummed to say it but I have to just let
it go like I can't get this done in time
Idaho when we were mostly talking about
it yeah
no it was before you called me you
called me I was in California and you're
like what if I helped you create it and
then we can get it done in the time
frame you want and people might be like
why were you so hung up on it getting by
this time I just knew that like after my
fifth baby too that like I just would
not have the time to like work that much
like I wanted to be able to slow down
consuming creating a product yeah and I
just wanted to like after the baby was
born to be like okay I'm gonna just
relax and just spend time with the kids
and not be so stressed with work you
know but I really also like it's a good
kind of stress because I I really wanted
to create it I just couldn't find the
time so that's when you called me and
you're like what if you're like leaving
the voice message a message like what if
we do it together and I'm like oh my
gosh yes that's what I need I need you
to help me create it yeah because like
while it was your brainchild like I also
like have my own we had very different
pregnancy experiences so it was like
your own important input yeah perfect
balance it was a nice balance to be able
to bring our different experience
experiences to the course and on top of
it we had the idea to bring in other
expert contributors yeah and that was
just perfect because there are certain
aspects that was really helpful to have
an expert and to you know to be
partnered with they're really powerful
wonderful women who just are also
passionate about um Parenthood and and
birth and um yeah I mean we've talked
about the course on our other platforms
but yeah
did you know that you swallowed five to
seven percent of your toothpaste every
single time you brush your teeth that's
an entire blob of toothpaste every seven
days most commercial toothpaste are
filled with harsh chemicals artificial
flavors and preservatives not stuff you
want to be putting in your mouth let
alone eating that's why bite makes dry
toothpaste tablets made with clean
ingredients that are sulfate palm oil
and glycerin free and my holistic
dentist fully approves there's a
specific ingredient she highly
recommends for brushing teeth called
hydroxyapatite and it's in these awesome
toothpaste bits and on top of that the
jars are so pretty it comes in
refillable glass jars and they send
refills in compostable pouches is so
they're better for our bodies and our
Earth no more plastic toothpaste tubes
bite toothpaste bits are so convenient
you just pop a bit in your mouth chew it
up and start brushing it'll turn to Pace
just like you're used to but with no
plastic tube or messy paste which makes
it extra convenient for kids who think
popping a bite in their mouth is so fun
and makes tooth brushing a pleasant
experience it honestly felt a little
weird at first but now my whole family
is obsessed it's so effective and makes
my teeth extremely clean it's literally
the best toothpaste I've ever used bite
makes plastic free alternatives for
everything on your bathroom sink from
toothpaste mouthwash toothbrushes and
deodorant so you can cut out the harsh
chemicals and plastic waste without
compromise and bite is offering my
listeners 20 off your first order go to
trybite.com Ellen or use the code Ellen
at checkout to claim this deal that's
t-r-y-b-i-t-e.com slash Ellen a lot of
people are asking about newborn phase
and I feel like sometimes when you're in
the newborn phase you just have so many
questions yeah that's how I was
so what advice do you for people now no
no not me you because I only did it once
and I'm like what even happened two
years ago I almost feel like you learned
the most in the first one yeah I mean
maybe not but to me I feel like the
first one is the most intense because
it's such a like a world view [ __ ] like
a World Experience shift yeah that you
didn't have before
um but I think a lot of times people
just don't feel prepared for it once
they get there like you think before you
get there oh I got this this is great
and then it happens and you're like whoa
oh my gosh yeah you're like I laundered
my baby clothes and they are folded in
the drawer I'm ready I am so ready for
this I got the diapers and I know I'm
gonna be like a positive respectful
parent let's go then you have the baby
and you're like oh my gosh this is like
a train hit me in the face I don't think
I've met a single new parent who was
like
it's not the heart like easy it's so
easy like everyone's like oh my gosh or
they're occasionally like the people who
are like my baby's so just easy I think
it's because I'm such a like easy like
I'm just got that like chill Vibe
because I meditated while I was pregnant
yeah I just had such positive experience
like you know so positive mindset in my
pregnancy I think that's why my baby's
so easy and then you just like kind of
Nod your head silently okay and then
once you have you just wait till they
have the second pin and realize that
like every kid is different every baby
is different yeah yeah and it's really
they kind of come out who they are I
know oh it's so interesting it's amazing
I mean there's obviously nurture
involved but sure I am someone who has
so many questions and I I really like
to I just I had just asked so many
questions almost too many you know but
it's okay to like ask questions learn
from the people you respect and from
people with multiple parenting Styles
and then and then stop and then just
listen to what your heart says because
generally your heart's gonna tell you
you're the right mother for this baby
and
no one else is going to do a better job
than you and if you just keep reminding
yourself of that to trust who you are
and trust yourself as a mom if you're
going to make more confident decisions
and you're likely going to
um go back to
primitive isn't the right word I think
but more natural like parenting
decisions because that's what's inside
of us you know like does it feel natural
to XYZ
that doesn't feel right you know like
yeah it doesn't feel right to you it can
be really easy to compare yourself to
other yeah other parents and moms or
anybody online like even someone like us
to be like oh they have it all together
but really I don't think anybody has it
all together everyone's just trying to
figure it out and do their best and it's
a whole different ball game like raising
kids is it's it's a thing it's like it
takes a lot of mental balance and
Clarity to just like trust yourself and
take the advice from others that you
look up to because a lot of times I'm
like what is somebody that I really
respect like what are they doing because
I want to do what they're doing like I
like I like what I'm seeing like what
and then getting advice from them yeah
and that's really helpful but then at
the end of the day you have to just go
with your own
intuition like you said and trust your
instincts
yeah and I think I think the tumultuous
sort of
um experience happens because when you
go from childless to having a child
you're going from this sort of orderly
life even if you're not an orderly
person you have your routine you have
things under control
um you are the keeper of your world and
you can decide when you go to the
bathroom and when you
roll out your yoga mat and when you
start chopping your salad and just
little things to take care of yourself
and it's just you have so much control
over your day and then a baby gets
thrown in and you're like what now I
have to respond to his or her needs and
his or her needs don't actually go by
the clock as much as the books try to
convince you that the babies are robots
and you can train them to be exactly who
they're supposed to fit according to
their phases and how what how many
months they are they're babies or babies
they don't care that by seven months
that they are supposed to be sleeping
through the night or whatever it is you
know like
babies are humans and they are not
robots I think that's like what I kept
reminding myself when I was in the
newborn phase like this is a child who
um is just needs me and try is trying to
figure out the world and trying to
understand the littlest things and they
are not dogs or robots that you can just
get to step two come on Von trap
children just follow me you know just
like to just follow in line exactly as
you see fit and what's so freeing what
some of the best advice you gave me when
I was like college every other day like
okay now he's crying I don't know why
you know your advice was roll with the
punches and I that phrase really stuck
with me because
rolling with the punches just means
um being okay with chaos and maybe chaos
is hard for certain personalities and
maybe chaos is just crying when you
don't expect them to cry or waking up
earlier from their nap than you want
them to and
oh no I need to get work done but all
they want to do is be held so I got to
figure out how to put them in the
carrier and get them comfortable so I
can like it's more chaotic when you have
a child to take care of going from not
having a kid yeah and actually that is
something that I think can cause a lot
of unnecessary stress yes in the first
time parenting mode because every time
they're crying or every time something
isn't going exactly how you thought it
would it can be easy to be like why is
this happening yeah like why why is the
baby crying like why why can't I get my
baby to stop crying or what what is
what's going on here why have my baby
poop this many times or whatever you
know it could be so easy to just like
need the answers but then I learned the
more kids I had that like you don't
really need the answers all the time you
just need your motherly intuition and
your motherly love or the parent love
right like that could be fatherly love
too like all you need is your love for
them and doing your best to figure out
what they need in that moment because
they're doing the best to communicate
with you and you're not always going to
know why like it's like it's not gonna
be
something where you're like aha I
figured it out it was this exact flash
card yes according to this cry yeah no
it's not like that at all it's just like
not how parenting goes and like for new
parents just like letting that go and
just taking that stress off your
shoulders and be like just realize that
you're just just be there for that
baby's gonna respond better to that yeah
your energy by your calm energy will be
so much easier to just navigate the day
with your child rather than just trying
to figure it out and I think so much of
my energy was spent on like
I don't know sleep was a huge thing you
know like incur like longer naps and
good bedtime and all that stuff and like
I was so focused on like it fitting this
like ideal or this what I called yeah
this mold
um and I when I looked back I was like
there was never a day there was never a
day where it went exactly according to
plan it isn't that sort of frame because
then it's like you know what it's never
gonna go according to plan and if you
let go of the plan and just embrace the
moment you're gonna be a better parent
yeah and presence with your kid is
probably the best the best way to
navigate your day with your kid instead
of being like it has to go this way I
have to have the house clean like this I
have to make sure my kid isn't ever
crying for this or whatever like do
babies cry and the house gets messy like
that's just what how like they're gonna
have food all over their bodies like you
know just things like that and just
realizing that like your love and your
presence is the is the best the best way
to guide you you know yeah I know and
and there's some like great books out
there there's some great resources but
what did we do before these books and
resources I I think we've lost our way a
lot when it comes to raising kids and we
live in a very different world than we
did hundreds of years ago
um but generally if we tap into
how can I respond and you know that's a
big thing the way you and I parent is
responding to our baby's needs there is
a different way of parenting where it's
we're sort of like re like
ignoring's not the right word but um
kind of forcing your baby to uh not have
the needs that
instead of saying like yeah like it's a
non-responsive type of parenting which
is is not my jam like I will always
respond to my baby's needs as they get
older you realize like okay we can start
having more boundaries and not saying
yes all of the time you know and as they
get older and older it does change but
when they're newborn yeah you respond to
their needs and that's all you really
need to do yeah and the book the book
thing that you mentioned is probably one
of the biggest reasons why there's so
much concern in questions over like
sleep baby sleeps it's like it has to
happen this way well this person's baby
is sleeping this way through the night
why isn't my baby sleeping this way my
baby wakes up so much and you know like
how do I get my baby to sleep tonight
that's probably one of the most common
questions I get is like how do I get my
baby to sleep tonight and you're like
and I'm here to tell you I don't know
I have no freaking clue guys this baby I
still don't know it's literally like the
books are just like too overwhelming for
me and it's just like I'm gonna go with
my intuition I'm just gonna follow my
baby's like okay but dagni's an awesome
sleeper first baby that I have had that
was like whoa was this fifth baby was
Dagny I was like oh my gosh what you're
only waking once or twice a night that
is a miracle that's a dream for me like
I'm like sure I'm down for that and I'm
here for this one like should we go for
number six no no I'm just kidding but
the point being it's so easy the point
the point being that like every baby is
so different I I truly found that to be
the case because like we had a really
difficult time with the first our first
baby and we thought oh later down the
road I was like it's probably because we
didn't know what we were doing you know
like we probably made it worse and yeah
we probably did on some level but then
the second and third baby came around
they were just easier sleepers and it
was like oh yeah I think I think we just
figured it out like we like we get it
now and then the fourth year we came
around I was like oh nope never mind we
really don't know what we're doing this
is just every every baby is different we
I just found that it was like that's
just
really assuring for people listening
yeah there's so much pressure from
grandmothers and mothers-in-law to you
know your baby should really be sleeping
through the night like you really should
sleep train them and if you're not if
sleep training doesn't ping if that
doesn't resonate for you you don't have
to like yeah people there's there's
mothers walk around with you know 14
months old who are still up two or three
times a night and yeah it just it's just
a reality babies need support like
motherhood doesn't stop at night time
Parenthood doesn't stop at night time
you're still parenting at night it's not
like I'm done off the clock as much as
you'd like to be out of the clock it
just doesn't work that way and uh I will
say that there has been one thing though
that has been helpful out of all the
resources I've come across like whenever
somebody like emails me or something and
asks a question if I'm able to get to it
um there's this one article called like
changing sleep patterns in the family
I'll put a link below I don't know
exactly what it's called I can't
remember the exact title but it's by a
pediatrician who is like look I'm not a
fan of like sleep training but um I know
that parents some parents are gonna want
feel like they need to do it and want to
do it are going to do it regardless so
this is a way that he's had suggested
for like the most gentle way to teach a
baby to sleep through the night when
they're over a year old and his emphasis
on over a year old like really spoke to
me that's like yeah like waiting until
they're older and they're like more
aware and understanding of like their
safety and their surroundings that their
parents are there and
um easier to teach a child and just like
it just makes more sense to me it just
like resonated with me so we have done
followed those rules in that not rules
but the guidelines and recommendations
in that article with a few of our kids
and it really did really work really
great for a couple of them one of them
it was just it just kind of backfired
and it was like oh this is just not it's
just not gonna go the way we thought it
would so it's like I said again it's
really just every kid is so different
and it can be so easy to want to compare
to other moms and thinking it has to go
this way and you might have even found
yourself judging other moms before you
had kids yourself being like Oh I would
never do it this way I would I would
never I would I would never do what
that's parents doing right now like you
see a mom before you have any kids like
I definitely did this where I was like
oh I would never do it that way like and
then I go and have a kid and I'm like oh
I actually I get it I kind of want to do
it that way and you just kind of you
just have to go with the flow and not
judge other people and not compare
yourself to others that is like such
probably the biggest thing that I've
learned throughout this whole thing like
don't stop comparing yourself to others
just focus on your own like parent
instincts and and don't compare your
children to other children yeah that too
I just launched a birth course called
the empowered pregnancy and birth that
I've worked so hard on these last months
and I've never been more proud of
something I've created this course is
filled with everything I wish I was told
before I came pregnant with my first
child over a decade ago go to have an
easier quicker labor and even a
pleasurable birth experience I created
the course with my sister Hannah McNeely
and we have some incredible contributors
in this course including Dr Gemma Newman
who collaborated with us on Play it
Forward prenatal nourishment she's an MD
who's a senior partner at a family
medical practice that has worked in many
Specialties including obstetrics
Gynecology and Pediatrics we have Haley
Callahan a donor certified Doula who
collaborated with us on having an
empowered birth for those choosing a
hospital setting we also have an
incredible yoga instructor Michelle
Minch with prenatal yoga classes in
birth meditation and finally Heather
McCain on the Mind change method and how
to rewire your brain for a more
pleasurable and gentle birth experience
which is one of the most powerful parts
of the course in my opinion because
something like Hypno birthing for
example can be really helpful for a lot
of women but for many women like myself
you can say all the positive mantras you
want out loud and envision the birth you
desire but if your subconscious believes
otherwise and tells you uh-uh that's not
what birth feels like I know what the
movie showed me it feels like I know
what my mom and friends say it feels
like I know what my past birth
experiences even felt like then it's not
going to get you very far that's why we
have to rewire our brain and change not
only the conscious mind but also the
subconscious mind and Heather someone
who's helped so many women like myself
achieved the birthday desire shows you
in this course how to do that this
course is centered around becoming
empowered and making informed choices
optimal pregnancy nourishment giving
birth where you feel safest getting back
to birthing wisdom and my favorite part
how to have an easy quick and
pleasurable birth experience it's filled
with how to prepare your mind and body
for conception creating a birth plan
that's right for you we also go into
nutrients of focus healthy foods to
embrace and supporting your body through
movement how to get baby in the optimal
position for birth and the secrets to
avoid tearing how to have an easier
labor guaranteed and the information
that made my last three labors
significantly more pleasurable gentle
quick and easy than my first two we
include everything you need to know
postpartum breastfeeding and more and
there's even a lesson for your partner
if you have one in how they can best
support mama in pregnancy labor birth
and postpartum so you can get access to
the course at ellenfischer.com or click
the link in the show notes and
description box just click the link to
learn more about the course I've never
been more proud and excited about
something I've created birth is
life-changing and I'm really passionate
about sharing all that birth can be
gentle peaceful easy and even
pleasurable
um I know we did the the that article
too which is super helpful so we
basically sleep trained at 14 months I
like to call it sleep teaching sleep
teaching I yeah I mean we say potty
train just the train just sort of has a
funny taste in my mouth because it's not
like I'm training a dog but um but yeah
sleep sleep taught at 14 months and it
worked it was awesome and I'm just so
glad that we we that article is
generally for
um parents or families who co-sleep
or even in the same room even if they're
not in the same bed there's some sort of
co-sleeping happening
um and then they're ready to get some
sleep I just remember feeling so
desperate at 14 months feeling like it's
yeah yeah and that's why every parent is
gonna go by at different times yeah and
so
with every parenting experience there's
the highlights there's the highs the big
love like beautiful baby you just loves
like how sweet they are in your little
child and then there's the hardships and
the struggles and just realizing that
like every parent goes through that I
want to recommend an Instagram account
do you follow hey sleepy baby
she's really awesome because she's
she just speaks some serious truths
about sleep training and about um
co-sleeping and supporting even Toddlers
and sleep like some toddlers still need
support to go to sleep my son does and
um just she's so honest like she I think
she's having her third baby right now
and
um she'll even talk about how like hey
we you know we got sick and so things
got thrown off and I just really
appreciate the honesty because other
sleep accounts that I'm not a fan of
just act like just follow my PDF and
everything will be okay you know like
and your child will be sleeping through
the night in one day yeah like just just
give it just give it one week and your
baby will sleep through the night and
never wake again it's just a lie like
children wake up and every child's
different like our friend has a
four-year-old who still wakes up like
every other night or so wakes up comes
crawls into bed with them and just
children are children yes yes and hey
sleepy baby check her out she's awesome
yes and it's also I mean like it it does
influence a bit it is influenced by how
you handle those experiences on some
level as they get older like how you
decide because I kind of went through a
period where I was like well they'll
just learn how to sleep on their own
right like they'll just they'll just
figure it out like please don't but yeah
that from my experience and from my
friends experience like it really
doesn't work that way it doesn't just
like one day they magically learn oh I'm
just gonna sleep through the night and
stay in my own bed or whatever it just
doesn't work that way you kind of have
to teach them just like you teach them a
lot of other things in life yeah I mean
at least that's just my experience maybe
there's some moms out there like no
really one day I woke up in there
swimming the other night I've just never
heard of it yet yeah it generally is
something that you have to teach has a
little effort yeah so if you're if
you're in a place where your baby's like
two years old a year and a half old and
you're like okay I don't want all this
crying I don't want to do a ton of
crying and I don't want it to be a
really big struggle but I also really
want to be like sleeping through the
night now and I feel like my baby's
ready or my toddler's ready to be
sleeping tonight I personally I don't
think you should just be like one day
it'll happen on its own like you kind of
have to influence it a bit you have to
help teach them or else you might have
that part where your child's four years
old and they're still waking you up
throughout your bed this family they do
they do set boundaries it's just
kids are kids like it's like their other
kid doesn't do it but this kid does yeah
yes totally what are you talking about
like every night no not every night oh
it's just like a oh yeah go through
phases where like he'll wake up a bunch
and then yeah yeah totally there's like
there's gonna be things like that that's
just parenting and I think it's just as
you get older you start setting
boundaries and it just because you're
setting boundaries it doesn't mean
you're not a gentle responsive
respectful positive parent I'll do I'll
throw in all the adjectives there yeah
um like you can like for example the
best example I can think of is
sometimes your kid doesn't want to get
in a car seat but it's the best thing
for them it's for their safety right so
sometimes you have to set that boundary
this is what we do we sit in a car seat
and it require might require a little
bit of physical maneuvering in there it
might require some crying yeah there are
certain things that are really important
that you establish and do for their
safety for their health and if sometimes
there is some struggle that like
struggle doesn't equal bad yeah yes
there are certain things that just take
effort and teaching and it's just more
like just having Grace for one another
having Grace for children not judging
other people and just like doing your
best and it comes down to like for me
where I would like take and listen from
different modalities of like okay what
is a sleep thing how am I going to do
this talk to different moms I would
definitely like talk to different moms
who are like like seasoned and then I
don't know if that resonates and overall
over time I found what made sense for us
because it depends on each kit too
um can I say one more thing about the
newborn phase yeah because my child
Cosmo is turning two in a couple weeks
and um I was thinking about this the
other day
that it's so weird to think about I was
bad I was in that newborn phase you know
I'm I'll be real with you guys I'm not
much of a baby person and I think it's
okay you cannot be a total baby person
and still have children so like I'm at
the two-year-old phase and I am obsessed
like it's so much fun I just feel like
I'm laughing all he's hilarious maybe
you thought you were a child a baby
person until you had a cosmo
I don't know you still think you're not
I'm not a baby person but you're your
baby person I love my baby you know and
when he was a baby I was like I was like
look at my baby isn't he amazing like I
just was yes I love my baby but you can
still be sort of like whew that first
year is hard if you're not like a
full-on I love baby even if you are a
baby person that's still it would still
be very hard it's hard and like I just
want to give encouragement to anyone in
the baby phase that like
the tear phase is my favorite oh so much
I agree I do not understand this whole
terrible Tuesday no it's not terrible
twos two is like my favorite age yeah
two is so much fun they're hilarious
yeah their little personality is shining
they're just showing who they are more
but they're also still in the very like
I want to snuggle you mommy type thing
oh and it still holds my hand everywhere
yeah and like he has perfected his air
guitar and he's like oh just but it's
hilar actually though like every age is
pretty amazing I know like because as I
get older like I love the age that like
Sandy and Elvis are at like they're uh
seven and almost 11. I'm excited for
that face yeah like it's super fun
because they are like your buddies
they're those just your close friends
that you can have really awesome
conversations with and they're just
shining who in who they are as people
um yeah I just love I just I mean I'm a
baby person I know you are absolutely I
mean I love it and I love your babies
I'm just you know
you know I I just it's okay to not be a
baby person like you don't you can still
be a womanly you know goddess mother and
still not like be a baby person you
could still I think when you say that
I'm it's hard for me to see because I
you're so good with kids like you're so
when I see you with my kids like I think
you're great with kids I'm okay I feel
like I'm better when they're older like
the older they get the easier it is for
me sometimes I'm like what are you
saying that's right and some like Andrew
Andrew is just such a baby like a kid
well actually he's just a kid person
like kid baby person he just like is so
great with us just swooping them up yeah
getting them totally mesmerized and like
having so much fun and whatever he does
with them like when I'm holding someone
else's baby even Dagny I'm like I don't
know what to do like hold on but it's
really for anyone who's like little
football anyone who is in Hannah's yeah
true anyone who's in Hannah's camp where
you feel that way once it's your baby oh
it's so different It Feels So natural
yeah it really does like once you have
your baby I definitely felt that before
I had kids where I'm like I don't know
how to hold this baby baby but then you
give birth and suddenly you just feels
so Primal and natural and instinctual
and you just hold your baby and it feels
so right yeah you know like natural so
you're really excited to homeschool oh
my God oh my gosh oh yeah homeschooling
that's how you're homeschooling how are
you going to homeschool in Idaho for
anyone doesn't know she lives in Idaho
now I moved to Idaho
we don't have to talk about that but oh
I moved to Idaho I love it mostly
the end okay so I no I I do love Idaho
Idaho's awesome and if you're vegan
living in or near Boise please message
me I need more vegan friends okay so but
you don't need just vegan friends you
already know obviously I have lots of
not being good friends but like it's
just something nice about having friends
with like vegan families and like I
don't want Cosmo to be the only vegan
kid around like I want I know there's
other vegan families out there
here's my beacon call me okay so
homeschooling
um I am so excited to homeschool I just
told you the other day how excited I am
to homeschool that I almost feel like oh
reel it in Hannah like have lower
expectations because I might be like oh
gosh this is really hard you know
because it is like I don't think you're
gonna feel that way I feel like you're
gonna love it because I love education
and you love and just all things
learning like you've always loved school
and Harry Potter yeah whole Harry Potter
projects here a whole year of Harry
Potter Harry Potter yes a whole subject
on Harry Potter yeah I'm like so into
I'm not like great at math But Eric
literally does physics and calculus and
trig for a living so I will leave that
to him you know
um but
I'm I'm so excited to make learning come
alive which is the beauty of
homeschooling like we were just chatting
the other day um because Ellen's in it
you're in it now like you're full on
like all the different stages you're all
the different stages and they're going
to like activities and um so many
activities I know and like they're doing
all the things like they're they're in
school now and it's like oh wait we
gotta do our school it's not like a oh
you want to learn the ABCs today like
it's a full-on yes when they're younger
and they're tallers it's easy to be like
oh let's just go to the beach today
we'll get to that later yeah like let's
just do a little bit counting in the
sand they're like oh you're interested
in this like I don't know it's less of a
priority yeah to do well when they're
done yeah I mean the thing is living is
learning so everything that they're
doing when they're little it's a really
beautiful way to start homeschooling yes
and then as they get older you do have
to be a little more intentional with
like the subjects that they're learning
and keeping on top of it and
not like the thing is though there's a
balance of both that's so beautiful of
being able to be really free-spirited
with homeschooling and like living is
learning because there's so much for
instance like finances math right the
math that's in school is not really
applicable to most people's lives unless
you choose a job like what Eric has like
being a structural engineer for a lot of
other people for the majority of people
like the math in school is not actually
applicable to life but what is really
applicable to your life as you graduate
out of high school and college is um
like finances personal finance and
that's something that I think should be
like a subject in public education
because so many people don't know how to
use their finances wisely and having
poor financial
finesse really affects your your
Wellness in your life it affects us
Society yeah which if that's what
education is about you know on a like
sort of holistic level is like how is
education affecting our society let's
learn about finances as kids like as a
collective for sure there's this quote
um this guy that I really want to get on
the podcast about homeschooling call his
name is Matt Boudreau and we've talked
I'm hoping to get him here because it'd
be super fun to have him on there's
something that he posted I thought was
really good I wrote it down it says
interesting Paradox you don't feel
qualified to educate your own children
so you answer that fear by putting them
in the same system that left you feeling
unqualified whoa
that's really good right who is this man
he's awesome yeah I'm telling you guys
you guys need to go follow him on
Instagram oh it's so good Ellen yeah
yeah it's like it's one of those things
where like why we feel so unqualified
but why do we feel unqualified like I
mean I don't I don't feel unqualified
but a lot a lot of parents can go into
homeschooling like they want to do oh my
gosh it's so good I never thought
I know where it's like parents were like
well I can't educate so I'm gonna let
them the same education system educate
my children so that they also feel
unqualified when they graduate yeah
isn't that crazy yeah and so I think
that's a really important core message
which we talked about in my last
homeschooling episode with my friends
josefa and Jenna if anyone who's
interested I love that episode that was
really fun to talk about homeschooling
um it's a very common theme for parents
to be like I want to homeschool but I
just don't feel qualified to do so or
someone asking someone like myself how
do you feel qualified enough to
homeschool your kids and what I have to
say is that you really go with the flow
again with parenting and coming back to
Parenting you go with the flow you do
what you do know and then when they get
to stages of things that you don't know
that's when you can either hire out or
find a homeschool community and
everybody has different strengths I also
think there's trial and Erin error
involved like I was just I don't know
why but I'm just thinking about
gardening because I was thinking like
I'm inspired by gardening the way I'm
inspired by homeschooling and I'm not at
homeschooling stage yet but I find both
like very happy feeling and sexy and
cool and fun and they're kind of the
same in the way in that you sort of you
try something it doesn't work and that's
okay you know it's life is messy and we
have so much like pressure around you
know making our garden beautiful or
making our children's education like so
perfect that it's this mold and the
reality is like uh compulsory schooling
has only been around for about a hundred
years and the way our education is
system is set up
is not actually connected to who we are
as like beings and it's not like whoever
said that that was like the way like
that's the only way that we can learn
that's the perfect way and it was set up
that way like in terms of their schedule
to fit with parents work schedules yeah
that's why yes they go to school from
seven to three or whatever and school is
like compulsory education is really set
up for one type of learner yeah you know
and so Hannah loved School growing up
you were just really good at it
naturally you didn't really have to
study for tests you just got it yeah and
I had to study really really hard and I
would still get like a B minus
um and I thought growing up like maybe
I'm just not that smart when really once
I got older I was like wait I am smart I
just have to harness what I how I learn
in the way that resonates with me best
instead of like you have to do it this
one way the way that schooling is so
school can be really great for some kids
but not every kid is like I love it
clarify here because while I did not
study I studied for one test in high
school I remember
being at the park like I should study
for my English test and that was my one
experience of studying however I was
super unprepared for college and I
remember one of my first papers I wrote
was a history like a gen Ed sort of
history class and I wrote a paper I got
a C and I went to the professor like
what I got us what and he was like yeah
this is a c paper but
I always thought hey what happened
and the truth is are um I don't think
our school really prepared me for
college
um and hmm that's interesting we never
talked about that
um
oh yeah the academics from our school
were definitely lacking um but that
doesn't mean I needed more rigidity or I
needed more like
push down your throat sort of like cram
I don't know like
Rory Gilmore at Chilton sort of
schooling that's not what I needed like
I I think I just needed more Challenge
and more like depth of thought and when
I got to college it was so challenging
and fun that's why I really stepped in
my game and that's when I became
studious while school was easy for me as
a high schooler Junior higher I was not
studious and I was not
I did not like literally when I would
set out to do my homework I was like I'm
Rory because I was really into Gilmore
Girls I'm Rory I'm doing my homework you
know and then it became like I'm
Hermione you know like just you don't
know it's just like I didn't want to do
math but I was like Hermione does math
well she does runes you know so I had to
like sit down and do my Ellen doesn't
know she don't she don't know about
Harry Potter but the point being that I
got to college and I really really loved
school and I loved being challenged and
I loved
um learning things that were hard
and that's what's so cool that
homeschooling is you can challenge your
kids yeah because most of the time kids
are super smart and we dumb them down
and in school it just like is too easy
yes oh my gosh I love the book dumbing
us down by John Taylor gotta did you
read it no but I went like this because
the title yes it's a short book but it's
by a public education school teacher
that won like numerous um
no State Countrywide awards for his his
teaching abilities and then he later
wrote a book saying that actually I
think that public education like dumbs
us down which was early it's really
interesting
um but that's not to put anyone down who
chooses to public school like there are
some kids that really thrive in it and
love it or even private school or
whatever form of schooling that you
choose I think it really comes down to
like individuality of every kid being so
different and some some kids are going
to thrive in it and others others might
not and also it depends on like your
life situation not everybody having the
ability to homeschool because it really
does take a lot of time so when I go
back to like find like the personal
finance aspect of like math and stuff
like Andrew and I are both like really
we really care a lot about personal
finances and being wise with your
finances and so that's something that
we're able to teach our kids and we have
the time to teach our kids that type of
thing it would be really great if that
kind of stuff could get into the like
standard public education system I don't
know if it's like that in other
countries but at least in America in
like high school that is not not like a
yeah
subject yeah
um the original question was how Hannah
is planning to homeschool in Idaho yeah
what what's your dream what do you what
do you idolize
well
so there is a a forest school that
opened up like
in 2020 and it's called ever wild and I
have friends whose kids go there and
it's essentially nature learning it's
play it's for you know first graders
that range it's not really high school
or anything yeah um for but it's what's
cool about it is while homeschooling can
be extremely
um expansive and integrative and like
very comprehensive
sometimes it's nice for kids to learn
from other people than their parents you
know so and just have another you know
form of authority giving them some
education and so you you send your kid
to Forest School however many days a
week I think you think you can choose I
think they got kind of expensive though
I think they raised the prices but I'm
still looking forward to at least trying
it out and it's essentially they go and
you know learn how to start a fire and
learn survival skills and learn about
hawks and they learn about prey animals
and and um yeah they are like in the
forest and it's all weather and so you
know if it's snowing out bundle them up
they're still gonna be outside for a few
hours which is cool yeah it's just it's
just a great way for kids to learn and
it's I'm sure it's similar to what you
guys have yeah we do for our older kids
like two days a week they go to a really
awesome school that goes to different
um nature areas around the islands and
do different sorts of aspects so on one
day a week they're doing like
volunteering at a farm another day a
week they're learning from like a native
Hawaiian and learning the Hawaiian
language and they do like meditation but
they also do workbooks and so they do
this and then they go swimming
afterwards and like a river and it's
like super great balance of different
yes different ways to take in their
education yeah and and I am excited to
have you know a community of other
homeschooling families and pretty much
everyone I know right now like I just
moved there six months ago so it's not
like I have my try but you know I know
some people there and I think everyone
is homeschooling as far as I know
um which is cool so there's already you
know people moms who are like trying
like I have a mom friend who's she's
like a very dedicated homeschool mom and
she's doing like a very Charlotte Mason
um style so I feel like I'm gonna pick
her brain a lot and and learn from her
and what's so cool about kids who
homeschool is they have so much time to
explore what they're interested in so
for example her kid is named Luke and I
was like if Luke is ever interested in
like I don't know
filming or starting a podcast or like
anything about media like send them over
to me for the week and like we I can
give them the rundown and yeah it's just
cool to if one of their kids is
interested in engineering come talk to
Eric come have dinner with us and to
talk more and it's just cool that you
have time to explore but what I Envision
or my dream is like having this cool
little I'm not really much of a routine
person but having a sort of Rhythm which
is the word homeschoolers use you have a
rhythm um where you have you know like
in the morning we're all gonna do yoga
and we're all gonna do yoga and um and
then afterwards we're gonna like eat
breakfast together and maybe even have
like an audiobook that we're all
listening to together while we eat
breakfast or something for half an hour
and then we move on like some sort of
Rhythm like that and then like Tuesdays
are hiking days or I don't know Harry
Potter days I mean I even need to
explain that yeah yeah you're gonna be
such a good homeschooler I'm excited
yeah
I love it I love homeschooling I think
it's so great when I am also like not
working so much that I can like be more
integrated in because right now Andrew
does a lot of it but as they're getting
older too it's so fun all the different
things you can explore together but you
know it's funny I kept telling Elvis and
Sandy and Scott was like Hey I want to
help like I love school so if you ever
need have a question come over here and
he's like okay
um he's like Hannah okay I have a
question about this I was like okay cool
oh it's math okay inside I'm like you
got this you got all right okay got it
they want to know how Okay divide why
did they subtract
I'm sorry Sandy I do not know
you're actually learning with them I
know it's cool yeah so like going back
to that quote that this guy Matt
Boudreau said like how easy it is to
feel like you're gonna just constantly
be in that situation oh no I'm not gonna
know how to answer the question but
really you're learning with them and
what a great example you're teaching
them to want to learn and be excited to
learn because I mean everything that
you're embodying as a person is the
example that you're teaching your kids
how to be so if life is full of joy and
happiness and like going after life like
that's what they're gonna do if that's
what your life is all about that's gonna
be them they're gonna they're just gonna
embody that too but if your life is this
like I can't I won't I'm not able to do
this like going back into your shell you
know like I like afraid of life or
afraid of being able to conquer what
you're most excited about like that's
what you're embodying for them yeah
Empower yourself to empower your
children yeah if you don't do that if
you don't take the power within you then
how are your children ever going to
recognize that in themselves it's just
like you know you want your children
either celery or the carrots you gotta
eat it too you gotta eat it first and
then they will yes your kids are total
mirrors and they're they're doing what
you do like number one you know because
it's quite common in parenting to be
like okay how do I fix this thing but
really most of the time a lot of time
it's in you I fix yourself this
um Rebecca Ian says that positive
parenting book it's like the only
parenting book I've actually read and
I'm reading and reading it it because
Ellen recommended it to me and I'm going
Ellen I am three quarters of the way
done and all she has told me is to work
on myself and my marriage it was
essentially what it is to improve
yourself as a parent yeah it totally is
like how we're being together as a
Partners is how they're learning how to
be with other people in relation with
other people how you're treating them is
teaching them how to be and that goes
the same too with this whole like don't
compare yourself to others and trust
yourself like all of this is is teaching
your children how to be too but this
also goes for people who don't have kids
if they're listening to this like the
trusting your intuition in life and not
comparing yourself to others because the
comparing game can be very very common
just in life where you look at some
especially now with social media I know
I know it's hard it's one of those
things where you it's really easy to
look at someone else's life and be like
oh I wish I had that or I don't have
that I'll never be like that or I'm not
as good or as worthy because I'm not
like that but I always go back to like
how jealousy is a thief of joy and how
if we look at comparison as the thief of
Joy yeah what did I say jealousy oh yes
comparison is the theme of Joy yes
that's what it is um but jealousy is
like is so different than being inspired
by someone like instead if you look at
someone's life in something that they
have or that they're doing like you can
look at that and be like what can I do
to do that too because I love what I'm
saying I do think jealousy can be an
amazing indication of what you desire
because some people don't know you are a
unique individual and that you
always sort of had Direction and it your
path was generally very clear and what
you desire was another question but some
people have questions about what they
desire like what do I really want and
it's easy to get sort of convoluted in
this world and um because we're
constantly comparing ourselves and if
you find yourself feeling jealous
I think that's a sign that you want that
too yeah and to how to change that and
harness that into inspiration rather
than jealousy because the jealousy is
going to get you nowhere you're just
gonna sit there and look at that and be
like oh I wish I had that I could never
have that and that's when you don't
Empower yourself yes I don't know but I
I'm like so excited to homeschool and um
I think that I
um I'm I'm so excited that it's it's
like a thing now you know like we're not
the weirdos off at the mountains in my
little lean too like homeschooling my
five children like it's like a thing
like super common yeah and I'm just yeah
I'm excited to jump into that oh wait I
think we're sure you've mentioned this
before but definitely read The Call of
the Wild and Free I've actually never
read that book what yeah it's really
good I should read it Kesley was like
not sure she's like always at the plan
to homeschool and then she was feeling
uncertain and I said read this book and
she was like thank you Hannah this book
literally confirmed everything about my
own philosophy of education and
parenting and then it got her connected
with the Wild and Free
um groups because of those groups and
anyway it's an awesome book yeah loves
that book yeah there's the money people
want to talk about money
hmm how about saving spending travel
you know something that I've been
thinking a lot about lately this isn't
directly about money but it kind of is
about money is
um the different phase of life that I'm
going into right now like my whole life
I was always looking forward to I can't
wait till I'm just like married and
having babies and I know that's so like
cliche like oh my gosh little girl hey
you're allowed to desire that and it's a
shame that in our culture you're not
allowed to desire that's so true that
was just really all I wanted I wasn't
like oh I can't wait till I have this
career this career like which is funny
and ironic because now I like do have a
career that I like absolutely love but
it was never something that I was like I
am going to do this with my life it was
just like I'm gonna have babies and I am
so excited to have babies and now that
we're like coming to the end even though
we just had a baby but it's like a new
chapter like it's like we are definitely
not a house baby this last baby this is
the last baby for sure and before it was
never like a girl like we are done but
now we know we are done and so it just
feels really weird to be like wait
what's the next thing I'm looking
forward to in life because I've always
been that type of person like okay
what's the next thing I'm looking
forward to you know which isn't always
healthy like you have to have a healthy
balance of like being happy in the
present and joyful in the present but
also having a healthy dose of like
looking forward to the future because
looking forward to something really is a
good motivator to like hard work and
stuff like that you know what I'm saying
um but with the healthy balance the
looking forward to the next chapter I
was like wait what is there what is
there to look forward to next like I'm
in it I'm in the thing I was always
looking forward to and I love it this is
awesome but like what's next like that's
so crazy even though what's next I have
like 18 years still because like I just
had my fifth baby but it's still it
still feels like it's coming to the end
of an era you know what I'm saying
because I love pregnancy and I love
birth and I love babies and it's like
wait I'm done I'm done with that part so
like now what am I excited about
bringing it back to money
it made me think of like traveling and
how I was like never I've never really
been like a huge big traveler like it
was never Something in My Heart I've
never been excited about traveling I've
gone a couple places but I have never
been like a big traveler but now that I
think about oh what would I want to do
once my kids are grown and I definitely
want to be like gardening with Andrew
like having more time in the garden with
him and then I also think it would be
kind of fun to like travel certain
places that I never I never thought I
would like want to do I'm like that
would be actually kind of cool to take a
whole month trip somewhere can I come
well all right for a week just kidding
just kidding yes I just like I
envisioned like you know Andrew and I
when we're like I know but yes yes I
have a good friend who um I had Cosmo
right when her daughter went to college
and we were talking about it how isn't
that funny we're both sort of in this
weird transition where
um I'm becoming a mother and you're
becoming an empty duster yeah and um and
and she was surprised she I think what
she was trying to communicate
was that no one really prepared her for
what that's like is to become an empty
nester and
um
and to suddenly not be needed as much
yeah and and that was that was a kind of
an interesting transition for her yeah
yeah and just can you imagine not being
needed you I mean our kids still need
you and you're like we still needed our
parents when we were 18 you know yeah
but in a different way it's just
different like I it's it's really hard
to Fathom the days where like we have so
much free time to do what we want and
the house is always clean without trying
you know what I mean like without having
to pick up every day like that is very
very weird to Fathom but it's one of
those things where I just never really
thought about life after having kids
like oh you still have like so much Life
to Live stuff yeah it's just weird to
think about I have another friend sorry
I make friends with middle-aged women a
lot I like some of my very favorite
people in my life were not in the same
phase of life at all but like we just
really connect yeah I think they just
they're just cool and they have no drama
and they're just very confident in who
they are I think that's why we connect
easily but she her her second kid is
about to go to college and her sort of
plan is like okay now I really need to
like get live in a place because she
doesn't have to live in that place
anymore like I need to live in a place
that my kids will want to visit me and
she's like I need to have like property
I need to be like they they like
snowboarding so they need to be near
snowboarding like I need I want them to
visit and she's like setting up her life
for like long term my kids want to come
home and bring their eventual you know
girlfriend's boyfriend's home and stuff
like oh that's so interesting I never
thought I mean you live in Hawaii so
it's kind of like not you don't have to
worry about that hopefully but I might
need to get a pool or something kids
come home just kidding we got a pool
uh yeah but that also makes me think
about just like being wise with your
money now because it can be very easy to
um just be in the moment and not think
ahead for the future and I have like a
whole personal finance episode with
Rachel Cruz who's the daughter of Dave
Ramsey it's such a great episode I love
that episode she was great but um it
just makes me think about how preparing
for your future and that's just
something that Andrew and I like just a
big like theme in our life is like
preparing for what's ahead you know and
it can be really helpful to like you
know save your money be wise be wise
with your money intentional with your
money you can spend things on things
that are important and valuable to you
doesn't mean you don't ever spend money
on anything yes but you're intentional
about every purchase yeah you know
instead of just like willy-nilly like oh
it's just I have the money now just well
I think what a lot of people get caught
up in is lifestyle inflation where they
get a raise or like you know maybe they
get I don't know class action lawsuit
payout like something they get money and
so there are automatic desire is to
spend more which
what if you flipped it and instead made
it a game to how much money can I save
because
yes there's things we can spend money I
spend money on food I like buying high
quality food and I like feeding my
family like delicious food I don't like
you know I don't know I like high
quality food it like makes me happy it
nourishes me it's for my health and my
family's Wellness but I'm not going to
spend money on a Chanel bag it like
doesn't I don't want to spend money on a
Chanel bag it doesn't bring me any joy
and so can you make those decisions
like what's actually going to bring me
joy and then also
try to like keep spending the same
yeah even when you make more keep
spending the same yeah that's how you
say that is like a like a very insane
way to live most people do not live that
way
um but for us that is something that
that we try most people don't live what
way like we're um live in a way where
you don't live in accordance to how much
money you have yeah you live like less
than half means below what you make and
people don't know the freedom in that
yes and that that can work even for
people who don't make that much money
um yeah and a lot of people don't know
that because you just think oh well I
don't make a lot of money like I could
never do that because I'm you know I
feel like I'm scraping by and some
people really are scraping by but
there's a great
um uh documentary called playing with
fire F dot I dot r e it's called
Financial Independence retire early and
that is a very inspiring documentary on
how to save your money now so that later
you have the freedom to go do what you
want like traveling or just gardening
and not having to work all day like
spend time with your family yeah because
work can take a lot of time away from
your family yeah because it is kind of
crazy when you think about it like that
we're all just supposed to we're
expected to work eight hours a day till
we're like 70.
that's like most of our life that is
that's so crazy I know so um well
there's a documentary talks about why
that system is set up that way I don't
know how to explain it but it is yeah
it's a great documentary I don't know
where to watch it right now you have to
buy it ironically yeah like spend five
dollars save all your money well you got
to spend to learn you know
um but yeah that's a great documentary
for anyone interested to like get
inspired with their finances and also
The Total Money Makeover with Dave
Ramsey yeah and I one of my favorite
Concepts is like you really think about
it is most people who look wealthy
aren't most people who look wealthy are
in a lot of debt yeah this is a truth
that people really need to understand
like really think about it your neighbor
down the street who's got those two
fancy cars that big old house sending
their kids to private school
how much money do they actually have a
lot of times they're actually the ones
swimming in debt they are like that and
stress yes and stress it's not always
the case but a lot of times that is the
case and so the people who actually have
a lot of money and are
um like very financially secure a lot of
times you would never guess it because
they're the ones we have people in our
lives yeah are very wealthy and you
would never guess you never need to
guess because they they they're sitting
on their the really old couch and
they're not super nice cars and you're
just like what how's that the thing how
is that the thing but um and that
doesn't mean you have to live like that
you don't have to live like in school
there's just ways there's ways to be
inspired by how other people live to
know how you can modify your own life to
be more comfortable and you don't have
to do everything not everything has to
be keeping up with the Jones yeah and I
think that oh hey I'm bringing it back
to our to our theme
what is trusting yourself because if
you're constantly I think people think
when they get in their 30s they have to
start buying nice things and not shop on
Craigslist and Facebook Marketplace and
like you can still get that 50 kitchen
table and make it look super cute and
um be really happy and guess what your
friends aren't gonna like you anymore if
you have that nice table yeah or
whatever it is that you're trying to get
they do then those aren't friends worth
having seriously I mean like I feel like
people think this that like I'm in my
30s now I need to own nice things I need
to have
the more square footage I need to you
know all these things is like do you
though like really tap in and ask
yourself or is this you comparing
yourself to others yes but there's also
the aspect of like you like we really
like to spend a lot of money on quality
food and other people their thing might
be their furniture and it's like okay
that's fine too if you want to have like
nice furniture but then like where are
you gonna find ways to save Ellen does
like nice things and she's like it's
okay
I really I really am one of those people
that like I like the nicer things in
life I'd rather have one nice thing than
10 not nice things I know but I think
there's a there's a difference between
getting you know a cheapo thing that's
gonna break fast yeah between
um I know you don't have good Facebook
Marketplace or Craigslist or offer up
here like it's really really bad on an
island but in Boise it's very easy to
find like great deals on feature that's
high quality like I got this amazing
bench for 40 I'm like this is this was
made a long time ago and it's very high
quality yeah it's gonna last forever
yeah yeah I have over time learned to
like be more
what's the word I can't think of the
right word were you just like not
needing to spend as much like Andrew is
just naturally not a spender yeah he's
well sprinkle just like implies like
hoarding on hoarding do you know what
I'm saying like yes like he's very
generous with his money but he doesn't
need to like have his to buy nice things
it's just like that's just how he is and
so it's been a good reminder for me but
I also still find the beauty in like
having one really nice thing that I'm
willing to spend the money on and then
other things um like where can I cut in
other areas yeah can make it in the
middle okay this is a really fun like
random I know random conversation mishap
on a bunch of different things but I
think that's how it will go every single
time you call my podcast I agree because
we're like what else can we like what
what are you gonna interview me on
Hannah tell me tell me all about that I
don't know yeah no we're gonna just like
have our normal sister conversations
because this is how our conversations
always go we're just like going up and
down and around on everything and you
inspire me so much obviously you do yeah
I mean I feel like we're constantly
inspiring each other I know and like how
to live our best life I agree and like
you should you should have those people
in your life oh absolutely I think that
you should surround yourself with people
who live the way you want to live
I'm just so grateful for that we're
doing this together yeah I mean that is
like something that people ask like what
do you guys disagree about and there's
really like we just like are on point in
like everything in our life like
wouldn't you say I mean we have
disagreements like I don't love Harry
Potter and you love Harry Potter you
know that's something but I mean it's
hard when you know I know it's hard
being wrong about things like that but
um
okay I like it our babysitter told me
she's like couldn't get into it and I
was like you're like excuse me um get
out of this house I don't think I can
have the energy in my household I don't
want you around my child just kidding I
love her she's amazing
um no we don't really disagree on major
sort of
but if we have we always like somehow
end up in the same place like we just
need to like talk it out enough and then
we end up being in the same place
pretty much you know what we disagree on
what is we see our childhood differently
oh yeah we definitely but we're
different people so we had different
childhoods kinda
it's just very interesting because like
even
other people I know they see like they
see their childhood differently than
their siblings I think it's kind of
common actually it is really interesting
like the first sibling second sibling
youngest sibling thing well the
personalities yeah but in terms of like
oh our childhood was like this yes that
just shows how much of in our head of
your reality is in your mind like that's
not to say Obviously there are cert
there are certain things that are like
absolute face truth reality of like what
happened in your life but there's a lot
there's a lot of room for um perspective
um interpretation interpretation yeah
yes okay I'm hungry all right we're
gonna end it now it's really hot in here
it's a lot this is so great thank you
for coming along with our conversation
and every time you come to visit
Meandering yeah every time you come to
visit we're gonna do an episode okay
like this we're just like we're just
gonna talk about a bunch of things
sounds good thanks for listening thank
you guys all right we'll see you later
bye
foreign
[Music]